يبحث الباحثون عن أشياء في
دراسة جديدة من المعاهد
الوطنية للصحة تجد أن الطمع يمكن أن
ينتشر إلى الجسم بأكمله في غضون
أيام ويبقى في القلب الدماغ
والأعضاء الأخرى لمدة تصل إلى ثمانية أشهر ،
هذا ما سمعته  يشير بعض الخبراء
إلى أنه مطلوب منذ فترة طويلة ولا
يزال هناك الكثير لنتعلمه عن
الأعراض التي طال انتظارها وتأثيرها ،
فلنناقش الآن مع الدكتور زياد العلي ، وهو
رئيس قسم البحث والتطوير
في نظام الرعاية الصحية في سانت لويس في
ميسوري ، هذه دراسة  لم
تتم مراجعة النظراء بعد ، لكنك سميت
هذا العمل المهم بشكل ملحوظ ، اشرح
ما هي الآثار طويلة المدى
للطمع ومدى ضعف عامة
السكان أمام
التعرف عليه منذ بعض الوقت الآن أولاً وقبل
كل شيء ، شكرًا لك على  استضافتي ما
عرفناه لبعض الوقت هو أن الكثير من
الأشخاص بعد أن أقتبسوا أقوالهم يتعافون
من الطمع الحاد في أول 30
يومًا من الطمع أو أول 30 يومًا من
الإصابة
يذهبون لبعض من  استمر في تطوير
معرفتك بأنك تعرف الضعف المستمر أو
التعب المستمر في ضباب الدماغ ،
وجدنا أيضًا أن الأشخاص يصابون
بمرض الكلى
السكري وأمراض القلب ، ما
تخبرنا به هذه الدراسة من nanais هو
أن هذا الفيروس  يُعتقد أنه
فيروس تنفسي كفيروس طويل أو
ينتج عن الجهاز التنفسي
عدوى في الجهاز التنفسي هو في الحقيقة أكثر من
فيروس جهازي يؤثر على كل عضو
في الجسم تقريبًا ، لذا أينما
نظروا إلى الدماغ فإنهم ينظرون إلى
الرئتين والبنكرياس والبنكرياس  الكلى
والكبد كان هناك دليل على حدوث تلف
في تلك الأعضاء ، كان هناك
دليل فعلي على وجود فيروس باقٍ بعد أسابيع
وشهور من الإصابة الأولية في
تلك الأعضاء
من حيث الأشخاص الذين تعرف حقًا أنهم
معرضون لخطر الطمع لفترة طويلة ، فقد يؤثر ذلك على
كل شخص تقريبًا.  يمكن أن يؤثر
كما تعلم في النقطة السابقة
فإنه يمكن أن يؤثر على الأطفال ويمكن أن
يؤثر على البالغين ويمكن أن يؤثر في معرفة أن
كبار السن يؤثرون على الذكور والإناث.  emales لذا
لا أحد بمنأى عن تأثير
الخفاء الطويل